So how do we analyze the data
because sometimes it can get, for
example, contradicting results.
>> Yes so it highly you asked
before what they love to answer,
you know that by now, it depends.
>> Right.
>> So
it highly depends on the question
that you're trying to answer, so
if you're trying to answer a question
such as which design is better?
Design A or design B?
There's not a lot of fancy
analysis that goes into that.
You have numbers that can either show
you that it's either A, B, or a tie.
>> So the majority of people decide?
>> If it's such a question that,
right, A or B.
But a more complicated question would be
>> Do I
have a good idea or not or
what do people need?
That's hard, not the majority,
sometimes I call these head-bangers.
When you see, only one person that does
something or behaves in a certain way,
you only need one person to
understand okay, this is important.
I don't care That the nine others
didn't demonstrate this behavior.
I know that this is important.
So it's not easy.
It's a team effort.
It's a team sport.
Research is never the researcher's.
If your startup is fancy
enough to have a researcher,
it's not their responsibility.
It's a team sport.
So the data is not going to
be always very helpful.
So what I like to do is have people
in the team be involved in that.
If you have an engineer, if you have
a product manager, the entrepreneur
himself or herself, a designer,
a marketing person, whoever you have.
Have all of these people coming
from all of these angles
observe the same behavior and
decide what's important here together.
That's going to be the way to
analyze and synthesize the data.
To decide together.
It's not always clear.
It's not always easy.
I would say this is
the hardest part of research.
Is understanding okay,
what is the result here?
What did we find out?
Sometimes, I use a tool that I created.
I call it, the rainbow spreadsheet.
So, the rainbow spreadsheet is
a spreadsheet that allows you to List
all the observations.
Everything that you see,
all the behaviors that you see.
And let's say you obverse, I don't know,
maybe five people, six people,
and then you just highlight or
color different cells to see which
participants we call them, people.
We invite to participate in research
demonstrated that behavior,
and then you get some kind of
histogram of what happened most.
And that's helpful in coming to
conclusions into what happened here and
what does it mean.